Carson is the dog and I am the cat in
our relationship he's like love me love
me love me love me and I'm like oh oh
think about what yet we ended up
stumbling upon this place and we walked
in and immediately we saw the tall
ceilings it had an actual place we could
park outside and I was like oh me take
my money please but we have as you can
see a lot of space to fill I'm a little
bit bohemian when it comes to my
personal style I know that Carson's not
as bohemian as I am um if we have a huge
room we're gonna need a big TV how big a
TV do you what um is there really a size
that's big enough hmm
search for the couch first obviously I
know couch look at that one
Wow you could seat like ten people on
that how much really nice let's make a
bid
chat with Nikolas why Nikolas why don't
you want your couch anymore it's
beautiful I think he's gonna love that
message standing desk but this one dad
this cool
I don't care where she lives I want it
maybe like a floor lamp oh that's cool
got a bunch messages yeah we can put an
emoji how about the drooling puppy that
says how much okay perfect I think
that's everything we're gonna go pick
something stuff up we're gonna start all
the way up in Studio City to get your
standing desk and then we're just gonna
make a big loop around going to West
Hollywood Koreatown mid-wilshire Miracle
Mile
and then finally back to Hollywood and
then to our house so it's a long day but
we do have one of the vans following us
we can put all the big things in there
like really easy and you're driving so
my dubs really easy it is you could just
sit here and do nothing I guess no I'll
probably keep shopping you know we have
so much we are so close to being over
our budget
I'm gonna look for like one more lamp
mmm let's look at throw pillows I'm just
going for plants it's so cool
[Music]
ah all right I'll to get the couch
yeah and then we're close to home but we
may need to run one little more stop oh
the TV
[Music]
that's awesome looks just like the huh
sure see Oh give ten oh he comes and
asks for change let's see if you're
lucky
hey all right man bye couch hello couch
[Music]
get the rugs and that leaves literally
just enough to get your TV it does just
enough oh my god you saw where all the
letters 4k HD 248 2 z LED yes I'm
honestly surprised that we got it done
looking around at this room it has so
much character our previous furniture
has all been from big-box stores and it
is not nearly this charming everyone we
interacted with today was so nice yeah
and like take their lightly used stuff
and like now it's part of our home and
that's just kind of awesome and I'm
shocked that Carson hasn't mentioned
this he got his TV I got the TV
[Music]